what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and once again I'm here to
discuss the absolutely crazy latest
developments of the demon slayer story
the fight between moolah and the pillars
is progressing extremely quickly so make
sure to stay tuned for that if you enjoy
seeing these demon save videos on this
channel make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is extremely
important ring that notification bell or
YouTube will notify you when you videos
come out also you might have noticed
that last week's video was taken down
because of a wrongful copyright strike
this is nothing new for YouTube anime
youtubers have always been dealing with
this we're going to do our best to fight
this and get the video back up however
since this can unfortunately happen any
time on YouTube
I ask you to follow us on instagram at
anime uproar linked in the description
where i will also be posting the weekly
chapter reviews if anything happens on
youtube you will still be able to watch
the full videos there for this reason
make sure to follow us on instagram at
anime uproar i will put the link in the
description in a pinned comment i cannot
overstate how much we meaning my brother
anna mac and i appreciate your support
of course there will be spoilers in this
video i will be talking about the latest
chapter chapter 183 after all you've
been warned
now without further ado let's jump into
this awesomeness as you'll remember the
last chapter had one of the biggest
twist and demon slayer we were shown
again jutsu AKA an illusion for the
muggles who haven't watched Naruto just
when it seemed like Mitsui the love
pillar and igor the snake pillar were
dead and 10 she was about to be killed
by moves on everything flipped me truly
an equal or showed up it was revealed
that none other than ushiro helped to
accomplish all this with help from the
pillars he invaded nakamise mind and
made her see visions that weren't real
since Mouzon has access to her mind he
thought that these visions were real too
which is why he finally lost his cool
when meets witty and eager off showed up
alive and well and interrupted his plans
you should know being the boss that he
is promised again moves on out of the
interdimensional fortress at the end of
the last chapter that way he would be
able to be killed by the Sun I have to
admit you should've went from just a
random side character who I didn't
really care that much about to being
epic AF brilliant writing on the
mangakas part there so that's what
to this chapter chapter 183 called
counter-offensive we see nosce Canal PS
a video is coming out about her in the
future and xeni - they're all together
somewhere in the interdimensional
fortress Anne's eyes was crying and
freaking out as usual it seems like his
character will still keep acting like
that even though he proved during his
fight against kagaku
that he can consciously step up and be
epic when it counts so thankfully we got
to see these guys again after so long
I've been hoping to see them but we
don't get to stick with them for long
because we jump back to the battle
against Mouton and unfortunately they
are not there yet
the fortress is switching around like
crazy it's very unstable as meet suti
points out the pressure coming off of
Mouzon is so strong it feels like she's
being crushed if she feels like this
with moves on I can only imagine the
pressure that Coco Chabot felt when he
was confronted by the strongest demon
slayer in history you're a chief anyways
we get some more comedic relief from
Mitsui
as she freaks out over how strong and
scary moves on is meet sir he thinks
about gilma and how she can't wait for
him to enter for her his presence will
be reassuring this gives us more insight
into how the other demon Slayers of
yugioh made he's like Goku for that when
he shows up suddenly everyone feels more
reassured that's a really amazing effect
to have on people so it seems like for
now yo may is the Goku and all might of
the series then meet suti reveals how
she ran into you shiro and how they
executed his plan she says that his plan
to pretend that the pillars are dead has
been ruined but hey they had to protect
tons you know he is the protagonist
after all they lost the element of
surprise now but at least our lovable
protagonist is alive the initial
exchange between meet suti and Yoshino
is actually hilarious
ushiro tells her that he is a demon but
that he's on her side he says that
unless she's a [ __ ] she'll cooperate
with him then she thinks I'm not a [ __ ]
and agrees how funny would it be if that
was one of moves ons demons but luckily
Yoshino really is on the demon Slayers
side in the flashback he explains that
while meet suti distracts the upper moon
he's going to infiltrate her brain
remove her from Moses control and hijack
her mind
then we have a bit of a meta moment
where Mitsui is impressed that he can do
that and says how convenient
and it is really convenient that you
show has the exact power that can help
stop moves on but that's always the case
in Shonen and the demon slayer mangaka
is poking some fun at the Shonan formula
even as she's also making use of it in
an epic way and I actually really
appreciate that after the brain control
takes place and me to the end
eager to save tons it off moves on and
you should all have a clash over upper
Moonachie maze mind this clash manifests
itself in the interdimensional fortress
moving around in strange ways that are
really unpredictable as our demon
Slayers are trying not to get crushed by
the moving fortress they realize that
they'll need to attack moves on they
need to distract them so that he cannot
focus as much on trying to retake naki
maze mind from you should Oh mousse on
realizes that tummy is demon you should
have is the one taking control knocking
his brain he thinks to himself that he's
got guts but that he's going to kill him
you got a respect you should run though
even Mouzon has to admit that the dude
has guts when an OPI enemy says
something like this about you you know
your boss moves on starts taking back
control and even starts absorbing you
should of selves you should or is
struggling hard as moves on is trying to
stop him from interfering then this
weaker demon hunter with him offers to
let you should or eat him if it will
help but you sure is not about to do
that while this mental war is raging you
and agura both launched an attack on
moves on at the same time to distract
him we finally get to see Igor in action
and I love it it's predictable but no
less epic seeing how iguras slashes take
the form of a snake someone in the
comments suggest that that ego is like a
young Orochimaru from Naruto but I
personally think ego is much cooler
anyways the two pillars succeed in
distracting moves on and that lets you
shoot or regain a more solid footing in
naki maze mind moves on realizes that he
won't be able to win the mental war as
he fights a physical one and with the
closing of his fist he tries to kill
knock you mate after Mouzon does this it
is only a matter of time before nakamise
cells completely die
Mouzon likely did this because he feels
it's better for the fortress to come
apart than for you sure to have complete
control over it
sure realizes that in the short window
of time he has left he has to get moves
on and all the other remaining members
outside not an easy task we jump to
tundra and as he's being thrown around
he sees a bunch of that Demon Slayer
core members he thinks that they must
have died with regret as he sees a
broken sword on the ground moves on and
the demon Slayers continue to fight and
then tangier off who already lost his
right eye gets hit by Mouzon again while
they're all jumping around and fighting
you go don't notice is that the fortress
is breaking up he points out that if
this happens and they don't get outside
everyone but moves on who is invincible
except for the Sun will die and then
just as it looks like Mitsui is about to
get hit by Mullins tentacle-like arms
tundra repays the favor and saves her he
throws the broken sword we saw in a
previous panel right that moves on it
hits him in the head and gives me to be
an opening to dodge moves on curses Tom
Judah the fortress falls apart but it
seems like you should or did its thing
since we see the sky and the stars the
fight is finally outside again where if
the demon Slayers keep moves on fighting
long enough they'll be able to kill him
with the Sun this was a great chapter
but I think the next one will be even
more epic we are probably going to see
everyone United again in the next
chapter even though we haven't seen
everyone outside yet I think you sure
will succeed in getting everyone out
then we'll not only get to see kill me
and sauna me join the battle but also
xeni to inosuke and cano it's going to
be all-out war with moose on if moose
law has more tricks up his sleeve like
another forum he's going to have to
reveal them soon and yes I'm fully aware
that in a literal sense Mulan doesn't
have any sleeves right now as we saw
with ushiro
everyone no matter how weak has their
own strength when all of these different
strengths come together in a good way
they will allow a weaker team of people
to beat a much stronger opponent we've
seen this many times in Demon Slayer and
black clover has some great examples of
this too with magic type advantages and
disadvantages excited before and I'll
say it again these creative paths to
victory are almost always more
interesting and entertaining to me then
when a character just gets super opie
and defeats everyone by himself and I
have no doubt that the mangaka demon
Serra has a great and very entertaining
I plan for us this seems like the climax
of the story after all so we can expect
her to pull out all the stops let me
know where you think we're going from
here well the team beat moves on and
could there be another villain after him
or will moves on escape and the final
battle will take place after some more
training I'd love to hear from you in
the comments below and that is it for
this video thank you so much for
watching
it's a real shame that the previous
chapter of you got falsely taken down so
it especially appreciate it if you could
leave a like if you enjoyed this one and
share it so we can help more Demon
Slayer fans see this one if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell so you
actually know when you Demon Slayer
videos come out and remember please
follow us on Instagram at enemy uproar
where you can watch all these videos
even if they get taken down here the
support we've received from the space
fan has been amazing and I just want to
let you know that I really appreciate it
a big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make videos
like this one possible I'm blown away by
the amount of patience we have and I'm
extremely thankful to each and every one
of you I especially want to thank our
pro hero to your patrons the one and
only gilgamesh baby ray nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson kings I'll just $30.00
beat a qiraji and anatoliy kot ski DJ
nathaniel alpha do and angel cruz and
are the one tier patrons the ones who
stay atop all clans stephen in grata
al-hola naught I'm Matty Mac 239
makoto-kun Seth Cooper and the world if
you enjoy work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon calm an
amine or and becoming a patron today for
as little as $1 if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access or
private patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
you
[Music]